In today's Cloud Minute I'm going to show you how to sign up for a free trial
and create your first project.
To start to navigate to
cloud.google.com and click free trial.
If you aren't already
signed in to your Google Account you'll sign in now.
Fill in your personal information. This form may look a little different
if you are outside the US.
Now fill in your credit card information.
Your card will not be charged unless you upgrade to a paid account.
We only collect your credit card information to verify your identity
and to ensure you aren't a robot.
Click to accept
the terms and condition and then click accept and start free trial.
It may take a minute or two for your account
and your first project to be created.
After account creation
you'll be redirected to the project dashboard.  From here
you can either follow one of the tutorials or you can start working on your own application.
I hope this helps you get started.